first of all the continued slow collapse
of that Dam which we've seen over the
last few days is absolutely consistent
with some sort of demolition charge
that's actually been involved in the dam
itself it's caused widespread flooding
all the way down the Delta as you can
see here and that's caused Devastation
across for lots of communities which are
labeled here all the way down uh it's
worth having a look at the down before
the uh the bombing as you can see uh
pretty consistent the sluice Gates
opening allowing a water to continue to
flow down but if you look at the
um the most recent picture we've got
um it shows the damage that's actually
been caused and as you can see there are
several areas of the dam which are
consistent as it gradually loses its
structural Integrity more and more of it
starts to go it is worth looking though
at um what who stands to benefit from
this for a monetary perspective for
Ukrainian perspective almost not at all
but from a Russian perspective it
protects one of their flanks all the way
down this River they were worried that
an amphibious assault might come it's
not going to happen when the terrain is
like this and it also gives a lot of
disruption to Ukraine when they would
want to be focusing on their offensive
but it's there's a huge but here though
the water will subside there's reports
already they're starting to subside
it'll take a while for the floodplain to
clear but once it has Russia can't blow
the dam a second time and actually
because it's summer gradually the ground
will dry and all of a sudden it will be
possible for Ukraine to actually mount a
potential offense across the danipro
river and whereas before it would have
been disastrous for them to be launching
an attack over that and then blow the
dam that can't be done again now so I
think what the lesson here is almost
certainly Russia has blown this down a
little early and from a military
perspective that Specter is now off the
battlefield okay and of course as you
say uh within that military perspective
of course the spring offensive that
we've been talking about for a long long
time now could we be starting to see the
start of that in fighting elsewhere
there's no sort of start line and
whistle here but we watch the phase zero
which was the ukrainians targeting the
depth of Russia now we're seeing
fighting all the way up front down the
front line which is the ukrainians
pushing hard all the way along front
line not a major offensive but what
they're doing is there's widespread
reports of of them fighting nothing from
the ukrainians at all but we do
understand that they're taking pretty
heavy casualties which is what you'd
expect because they're throwing
themselves at the front line of defenses
from Russia what we'll see though is
that once they find the weak points
that's when we'll see the punch that's
when we'll see the tanks brought to bear
the major offensive and potentially some
momentum for the time being
um just a lot of fighting along a long
front line